اشتعلت النيران وفي خزان الوقود بعد هجوم
بطائره مسيره في كورس بروسيا على بعد 100
كيلو متر شرقي الحدود مع اوكرانيا قبل
هاتف مهاجمه مطرين عسكريين روسيين بطائرات
مسيره اصابع الاتهام موجهه لاوكرانيا
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده التي تعتبر
الداعمه العسكريه الرئيسي فان الجيش
الاوكرانيه يتمتع بحريه التصرف خارج
اراضيه
على الاطلاق
لغه الدبلوماسيه على لسان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي
داخل روسيا
ينفي الغرب استخدام المعدات العسكريه التي
يقدمها لاوكرانيا خلال الهجمات على
الاراضي الروسيه رغم اتهامات واشنطن
بالتدخل في الحرب بشكل غير مباشر فيما يقر
الرئيس الروسي
بطول النزاع وانه لن يستخدم السلاح النووي
الا للضروره القصوى
تعتمد استراتيجيتنا على التوظيف الدفاعي
ونعتبر اسلحه الدمار الشامل والاسلحه
النوويه وسيله دفاع هي مبنيه على ما يسمى
بالضربه الانتقاميه عندما تتم مهاجمتنا
فاننا سنرد مباشره
لمنع استخدامها كوسيلته هجوم على روسيا
التي تسعى بحسب الامين العام لحلف شمال
الاطلسي السلطان
في اوكرانيا لتعزيز
مراتها تمهيدا لشن هجوم جديد في فصل
الربيع